E
RESENTATIVEGCRO
IT'S BETTER THIS TIME,
REPRESENTATIVE JONESHE M IN YOUT
VIOLATIONT ING THIS IS SOMETHIH.
EGREGIOUS TODAY THE
TY BECAUSEST BLACK LAWMAKERS
ATHEREDE FOR
DEMANDING THAT THEY AND
WE'RE BEING SPILLED, NOT BECAUSE
OFRIME, NOF TIOTISE THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE DEMANDING
THAT WE ACT S
AFTER NASHV TERRORIZED
BY SCHOOL SHOOTI COVTENTHAN
OF BANNIN WEAPONS.  FORMER
SUPERMAJORITY ARE ASSAULTING
DEACOULD THATSHOULDRE
TENNESSEE
HOUSEAKER CER.
KE DURING THE
PROTESTANRY INSURREIO THAT OUTHS
AT LEAST EQUIVALENT, MAYBE ON HD
RST TOONNAL.
I MEAN, ITS A COMPLETELYRIDICULM
REPRESENTATIVE SPEAKER SEXTON
REACTION WHAT WE'OI
THE OPPOSITE. WECALLING
STANDI OUR CON VIOLENCE WERE
BECAUSEOUR COMMUNITYON ON
INTERNATIONAL AND WON'T BE THE
ACT WITH
LEGISLATORS
GRIEVANCES OF THESE YOUNG P
HERE, CHANCE GOINGW
. PEOPLE WANT ACTION FROM THIS L
CONTINUE T LEGLAABLE
WHETHER I'M INSIDE THE BODY, THE
HERE IN THE WA DOETTIDOUSLY, YH
POINT. THE FACT IOU
DO HLOOR
WI BULLHORN. AND IT IS VIOLATIOE
IT AT ALL? WASRE SOME OTHERG
NISHMENTHAT WOULD HAVENACCEPTAB,
THIS CAME AFTER THE SPEAKER SHUT
CALL ON US DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS
TO SPEAK. AND SO IT WAS OURY
WAY TO UPHOLDST
TENNSEON ARTICLE
TWO SECTION 27 SAID THAT
LAWMAKERS A RIGHT
DISSENT FROM AND PROTEST AGAY AN
INJURIES TTHPLE BROKE THE
78,000 CONSTITUENTST OF
DEMANDING TWE THAT WSO AND THATO
NEED TO MA SATHOLETH,
THEIR DEMANDS OR GRIEVANCES WERE
HELD AND WERE HEARN THE HOUSE
FLOOR. I DIDN'GO TINDIVIDUAL. IA
REPRTIVE OF 78,000 PEOPLE, AND O
THE WELL. MAN OF MY COLLEAGUES
ACT ON THIS CRISIS OF MASS
AT IS PLUIUR
NATION. REPRESENTATIVE GLOAYOURC
PROTESTEDU STTODAY. SHE
SURVIVED BY ONE VOTE. DID THAT
RI DO YOU THINK
SHE IT WAS IURPRINKNOW WE ARE UW
HONEST ABOUT AND THAT AGAIN,
PROBABLY WHITE REPUBLICAN
SUPERMAJORITIES EXTEED MANNINGHA
BODY AND SO, UM WE STILL STAND
UNITED TOGETHER, BUT WHAT
HAPPENED? THREATENING NOT JUST
THE ES THE NATION
IS THIS.HE DEMOCC VOTERS
0,000 PEOIN DISTRICT,
MOSTER
STAT MEAN, IT'S
VERYCARY. THE NATIONSEENING HERI
TO ME. 53 2020 2023
PELY, WHATYOU DO?
AT FOR
THE NEXT ELECTION? IS ER
THERE'S TO CA THAT THE COUNCIL E
METRO COUNC
WILL HE HERE'S
ALSOAL. YOU
LEG
HAT I
BELIEVE IS HAPPENING HERE AND
TER TALKING TO ATTORNEYS IT WAST
VIOLATION OF OVERTURNING THEADET
XTREME MEASUREXPEMBER NOT FOR A.
VIOLATION, B O A RULE
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE.GAIN, IT
TODAY WAS TO DISTRACT FROM THE
REAL ISSUE. WHAT WAS THAT? A
WEEKNGN, RATHER TPAWS THAT PASSS
S EXPELLED
MYSELF, PEARSON BECAUSE
AF OF ICE TO ALL THESE YOUNG
MANNING HIS BODY CHANGED.LLENNID
BS AND URGENT ACTION TO
ADRISIS OF MASS
EP
TONIGHT. THANKO. JOINING US NOWR
TICALON BROWNSTEINDITOR
WHO IWI CNN. SODIE CORNISH
AUDIO, UH L JE, MB
FOLKS WHO ARE JUST JOINING U
ONJU
JOHNSON
PARTA N
FLOORSI THEIR MICROPHONES WERE
. SO THEY PROTESTED. WAS A VIOLH
VOTO
EXPLAIN WEG FOHIS. I MEAN,
APPENSEXT YEAR WL
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT
SEATS THAT WEREAC ALREADY NASHVM
A SPECIAL MONDAY DO
PLANRT OF MR. WOD YOU JUST HEARK
TO TOMSE
CHANGED I REALLY CAN'T
UNDERSCORE. HOW HOWANTRENAS TTRS
BEEN KIND OFTDD
REPUBLICAN HOW
RONALD HOW THAT IS REALLY
REFLECTIVE OF A TREND THAT'S
CROSS THE YOU
N. IT IS . AND WE
E THIS ON ELECTION N
TH OTHER 3000NAMICES IN AMERICAO
SEE AFTER
E METRO IN THE COUNTRY, AND
DEMOCR ARE CONSOLIDATING
THEIR STRENGTH INSIDE OF THAT,
AND REPUBLICANS ARE
STENING THEIRAN
, BUT I THINK WHAT
WE ARE SEEINN D STATES TT  FROM,
TO USE THISUE IN CALIFORNIAS IE
ATO  THE
ISIONS ANOW, VOTERS IN THOSE PLU
THEENERIO ING B
OF THESE STAT, THE
GENERATIONAL TRANSITIONRACIAL TN
OVERLAPP. THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLYNGLACES LIKE
FLORIDAR  TEXAS OR
TENNESSEE ARIZOE THEYVERNOR, ACE
, GENERALLY,
U  R COALIED IN THE OLDER
GENERAS  ARE
PRWHE  THOSE
STATES. AND A DRACOALIT
INCREASINGLYNGER
GENERATIONS IEIK LGBTQ
RIGHTS ABORTION
BANS AND BOOKAN AND
CLASSROOMSIP YOU SEE
THESE REPUBLICAN COALITIONS
MOVING TO IMPOSE OLDERTE
, PR CHRISTIANALITION BEFORE THS
, POSSIBLY THE BALANCE OF POLITL
POWER IN THEIR STATES. I'VEAT'SN
LEGISLATUR
SANDBAGS AGAINST TIDE. AND I IET
WE IN THE
THE L I. WHAT PROTESTS WILL HAVN
KNOW IF IT W IMPACT
ON THE LEGISLATURE. SO TOPEAK.
I MEAN, IT'S CERTAINLY BROUGHT
MORE SCRUT ON THEIR
ACTIVITIES, BUT I ALSO WANT
COME BACK TO A POINTDBO. ZLS. TT
WE'RE SEEING THIS GENERATION OF
ACTIVIST THELAWMG LIKE THE
NALL WHOUNIITD
ENDED UPEI. WHAT'S
AUT? ISREA GENERATION THA WATCY
? TH ARE A PVONTITHARE LIVES MAE
POLITICS AROUND SOTTHREON THEY
REALLY DO FEEL AS THOUGH TS E AD
TH JONES IN A WAY
IN PARLAD, ALSO
, THEYLL
EMBODIED MIX OF
SAVVY AND POLITICS AGRESSIVE POT
THD?, BUT ALREADY DO THAT. ANDIE
TH THE MORAL HIGH GROUND.
THERE ISGISLATEIF OF A REPRESEH
WHAT WAS CAL.